in the escalating war of words between
America and Iran Twitter is the
battlefield with two key combatants for
America tweeter in chief Donald Trump
for Iran the country's american-educated
foreign minister Javad Zarif this his
latest salvo earlier today Donald Trump
right lead applause military-industrial
complex he tweeted pushing us to forever
wars but allowing b-team to trash
diplomacy and abet war crimes by milking
despotic butchers via massive arm sales
achieves nothing but empowering that
same complex time to drain the swamp by
beating javad zarif is mocking Donald
Trump's national security adviser John
Bolton and Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo both known halts when it comes to
Iran I just don't want them to have
nuclear weapons and they can't be
threatening us I'm not one that believes
you know I'm not somebody that wants to
go into war because war hurts economies
were kills people most importantly you
come after that Iran tweet follows this
interview in which the president warned
Iran sounded less enthusiastic about the
prospects of war that did little to ease
tensions between the two countries that
have seen b-52 bombers sent to the
region and an aircraft carrier Strike
Group neither did this tweet from the
president shortly before he gave that
interview in which he threatened his
adversaries with nothing short of
obliteration if Iran wants to fight that
will be the official end of Iran he
tweeted never threaten the United States
again and today britain's Foreign
Secretary Jeremy Hunt issued his own
warning to the Iranians well I would say
to the Iranians do not underestimate the
resolve on the US side in this situation
they are not seeking a conflict they
don't want a war with Iran but if
American interests are attacked they
will retaliate
something that the Iranians needs to
think about very very carefully but the
Iranians are upping the ante today
reportedly beginning to quadruple the
production of enriched uranium bringing
forward the day they'll be in breach of
the nuclear deal the war of words is for
now just that and mainly on Twitter but
tensions are escalating making the
outbreak of open conflict more not less
likely Dominik Waghorn Sky News